- [Voiceover] On Wednesday,
Heather ran three miles in 30 minutes.
If she ran for 45 minutes
at this rate on Thursday,
how for did Heather run on Thursday?
Well, let's just think
about what that rate is.
So, the rate is going to
be equal to the distance,
the distance she traveled per time,
and this is going to
be equal to, let's see,
she traveled three miles,
she traveled three miles in
30 minutes, in 30 minutes.
You could simplify, three
over 30 is the same thing,
this is the same thing
as 1/10, 1/10 of a mile,
of a mile per minute, per
minute, that's her rate.
Now that's not what they are asking for,
they're saying, if she went
at this rate for 45 minutes,
how far would she run?
Well, let's just multiply
them, so 45 minutes times,
times, 1/10 of a mile per minute.
I can just copy and paste
that right over there,
so times that, copy and paste,
what are we going to get?
Well it's going to be 45 times 1/10,
or it's the same thing
as 45 divided by 10,
that's going to be equal to
four point five, four point five
and then the minutes cancel
out, minutes of the numerator,
minutes of the denominator,
four point five,
four point five miles.
Another way to think about it,
and this might even be an
easier way to think about it is,
well she's going to get the
same rate, if you're going
from 30 minutes on one day,
to 45 minutes on the next day,
you're increasing, you're
increasing your minutes by 50%.
Thirty, plus half of 30, 30 plus 15 is 45,
so the distance you travel is
going to be increasing by 50%.
So 50% increase on three,
would get you to, 50% of three
is one point five, you add that to three,
it gets you to four point five.
So, either way you want to tackle it.